first we go to Peter Navarro Peter
welcome great to have you with us
tonight Martha I know you're all working
very hard there to get everybody on
track and of course one of the things
that leaves people so unnerved is the
impact that it has on their daily life
with regard to work and their job and
being able to go to work and all of that
tell us a little bit about what was put
in place today to alleviate some of that
anxiety well Martha my job here at the
White House is to be a soldier out
making sure the supply chain works so
that we have everything we need to treat
our people so one of the things I did
yesterday morning I got a call from a
company called Pernod Ricard it makes
alcohol it makes
alcoholic beverages they had volunteered
to make a hand sanitizer using their
alcohol they had some obstacles so I
made three phone calls one to Treasury
one day the FDA one to HHS to clear
their obstacles out of the way in Trump
time quickly and today we got a
commitment they're going to start
producing on Friday and over time we're
going to have 4,000 gallons a week and
they're going to be able to send it to
the government at no cost that's the
kind of beauty we're seeing as we have
the full force of government and the
full force of business join hands to
help the American people absolutely by
the way these facilities are going to be
in America they're in West Virginia
Arkansas Texas and Kentucky so I think
one of the things that this is making a
lot of us think about is that supply
chain and one of the areas that is very
concerning is the amount of our medicine
and pharmaceuticals that we have handed
over to the Chinese to to to produce and
I know this is something that's very
important to you as well how quickly can
we ramp up that production here at home
what does that look like well for
example I'll give you another example
Honeywell offered on Friday they called
my office they say look we want to start
with producing within 30 days the
facemasks we can open up a plant in
smithfield rhode island all we need to
do is have you help us work with HHS to
get the ball rolling so on friday i said
okay get your contract and they got it
in by that night I called HHS over the
weekend then said yeah we're gonna flip
that within a couple of days and already
we have Honeywell moving towards that so
what it looks like is having the
appropriate incentives for our domestic
industry to produce these things like
face masks and hand sanitizer and all
the things we need and and what we need
long-term Martha this is this is the
problem we face the government does not
buy American enough the government the
VA HHS DoD tremendously large consumers
of medicines medical supplies and
medical equipment and so what we're
working with the President as we speak
to get an executive order to the finish
line which would provide long-term
incentives for our companies to produce
here and it's not this is not about
China because if you look at the
dispersion of that chain it's across the
world Europe for example Ireland
surprisingly enough Germany Switzerland
we're heavily dependent on their India
as well so what we've got to do is
through the three three things Martha
we're going to have by American we're
going to deregulate so we can get things
here done faster and most importantly
we're going to innovate to keep prices
down there's a process called advanced
manufacturing that we're working in
lightening speed to get switches flipped
on there so that's that's the big
picture we cannot keep having these
public health crises and go back to
sleep like the previous administrations
have this is going to be different this
time and we're going to get through this
and and we're going to be in a better
place over time because we're going to
produce things here in America yeah well
I think you know those are all things
that that had in the right direction
with it what about you know the current
concerns over enough beds enough
hospital facilities the question about
whether or not the Army Corps of
Engineers should be building some
temporary hospitals and medical
facilities we heard Governor Cuomo today
saying you know in some cases you could
move some people out of our hospitals
where the heavier equipment is and if
they're in in a in a healthier situation
not dealing with kovat 19 maybe some of
them could be moved into these temporary
facilities what's going on where's the
progress on on that what can you tell us
yeah Martha it's not really my Wain but
what I can tell you is that there's
action quick action within the Pentagon
working with the White House on those
kind of things what I can tell you
though is on Saturday I got another call
where we had to get some swabs for
testing over from Europe here and we got
the Pentagon basically to send a mil Air
flight over to where we needed FedEx
volunteered some some of its own
delivery planes that plane landed
military plan landed in Memphis FedEx
picked them up and we were able to
disperse 850,000 swabs across this
country so that's good Pentagon's
engaged and we're engaged last question
for you is you know sort of the big
picture that I open the show at tonight
in terms of that national anxiety what's
the mood at the White House and on how
to approach that because one of the
things that's going to happen with all
those additional swabs and all the
additional testing is something that
we've all said and we know but when you
start seeing it happening it's unnerving
and that's a big increase in the number
of positives out there in the testing
what what are you all trying to do to
sort of help people deal with the
anxiety of those rising numbers well we
we have essentially a wartime president
now and the war is against this
coronavirus we know what we need to do
we need to flatten that curve and we're
confident working together with the
American people doing what the CDC
recommends with government and with
business that we're going to get through
this to the other side of it we are very
strong people I can tell you this more
than we're doing everything possible
working 24/7 either here through
telecommuting and it's gonna be fine we
just got to work to get this through and
everybody's got to pull together there
can't be any dissension in the ranks
the other big thing Martha I got to say
this we got to get that
1.2 trillion dollar stimulus through in
a matter of days not weeks not months
that has to happen now because we know
we're going to have tremendous headwinds
in the second quarter we could get
through that and have a good bounce-back
we need 1.2 trillion dollars the
president is asking for that I think
there's there's basically support for
that on both sides of the aisle they
have to figure out what exactly that
looks like but I'm telling you take days
not weeks yeah you go just the cash that
goes back into people's pockets that we
heard the Treasury secretary talking
about today when they don't have
anywhere to spend it you know how
confident are you all that that's going
to provide a good stimulus if there's no
restaurant there's no movie theater
there's no Broadway show no you know
where does the money go well there's
there's a number of options on the table
one as a payroll tax cut which would be
a sustained a level of support through
the end of the year the other is these
instant rebates and there's a lot of
things in between here's the thing
Martha I've advocated a multi-vector
approach where we have a targeted relief
program like the Pelosi bill was passed
where you help sick people who you don't
want people to have the choice of going
to work sick or staying home broke so
that's that's one vector you got the
fiscal stimulus 1.2 trillion some form
of that you have what the Fed did with
lowering interest rates but also opening
the window for emergency lending they
may need to do that and then you need
the industry assistance and so if you do
all four of those things I got to stress
this more than it's like Congress needs
to understand you can't just do one one
of those things or two of those things
you got to hit all four points of those
companies president is adamant about
this and if we do this within days we're
gonna be just fine economically the most
important thing is the public health
emergency though and that's what I'm
working on the supply chain stuff thank
you for what you're doing Peter Navarro
thank you good to see you tonight